großbritannien trauert um prinz philip
der palast mitteilte ist der ehemann von
queen elizabeth der zweite im alter von
99 jahren gestorben
die queen verliert damit nicht nur ihren
ehemann und den vater ihrer vier kinder
sondern auch den wichtigsten menschen in
ihrem leben
prinz philip geld als ihre größte stütze
und engste bezugsperson
doch im november 2020 hatten sie ihren
73 hochzeitstag gefeiert
philips kindheit und jugend waren
geprägt von flucht und einer zerrütteten
familie
obwohl er ein geborener prinz von
dänemark und griechenland war hatten er
und seine familie nicht viel und wurden
aus ihrer heimat vertrieben
nach der trennung seiner eltern wurde
philipp jahre lang zwischen
verschiedenen internaten und verwandten
hin und her geschoben
seine einzige wichtige bezugsperson
seine schwester cäcilia kam 1937 bei
einem flugzeugabsturz ums leben
ein richtiges zuhause fand er erst
später mit der lese bis sie war zwölf
als sie sich das erste mal trafen er
fünf jahre älter 1947 rebif r 21 26
heirateten sie in westminster abbey
die radioübertragung von der hochzeit
hörten damals unglaubliche 200 millionen
menschen mit dem tod seines
schwiegervaters könig george dem
sechsten und der krönung von der
lesebuch zur queen 1952 änderte sich das
bis dahin weitgehend sorgenfrei leben
des paares schlagartig von nun an
standen vor allem pflichten auf dem
programm
doch philipp nahm sie mit humor mit
legendärem humor der zwar nicht immer
politisch korrekt war
das britische volk dafür aber umso mehr
liebte 73 jahre war philipp prinzgemahl
hier die royale familie und den
buckingham palace hinter den kulissen zu
sammeln
ohne ihn hätte die queen über 68 jahre
ihrem land dienen können
er galt als ihr eiserner rückhalt und
erarbeitete sich damit über jahrzehnte
den respekt der briten
das ist ein moment des staats trauerns
und auch im moment ist ein in der die
queen auch als königin agieren muss nach
chef des commonwealth sex ist für sie
ein ganz harter moment ich meine sie hat
diesen mann
das war ihre große stütze der einzige
trost sozusagen in dem moment ist
eigentlich dass die das ist den beiden
vergönnt war die letzten monate ihres
lebens sich sagen wir mal so viel zu
sehen wie sie sich sicher seit jahren
nicht gesehen haben denn corona hat
bedeutet dass er seinen ruhesitz der
eine eher auf dem estate von sendungen
hatte räumen musste und er musste
umziehen der windsor castle das heißt
die beiden haben die letzten jahre de
facto sich einmal die woche vielleicht
gesehen manchmal auch nur alle zwei
wochen die letzten monate waren sie
wirklich wie in isolation und das in
windsor castle eine sehr schöne
isolation aber dass die beiden sozusagen
am ende ihrer langen ehe noch mal
monatelang sozusagen seine late
honeymoon zusagen zusammen haben ist
ihnen wirklich vergönnt und dass er auch
nicht im krankenhaus starb
sondern dass die königin an seiner seite
war dass er in seinem eigenen bett in
windsor castle in seinem geliebten
appartement dort sterben könnte hänge
ist er ist eine große große gnade
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren